[Musique]
le jardin de l'état ouvert ses portes ce
mardi 13 décembre pour accueillir la
manifestation au bonheur des enfants
une cinquième édition placée cette année
sous le thème du cosmos on donne et on
offre du bonheur a à toutes les familles
réunionnaises saucette reda néon blanc
souhaite un joyeux noël une bonne année
et surtout de l'entr'aide de l'amitié de
l'amour est il bien qu'à l'intérieur de
la famille que ces valeurs là se
pressent encore le mieux protégé
venez venez venez passer un moment c'est
la période de noël venez dans ce
magnifique jardin de l'état qui a été
aménagé je suis ébloui et vous le serez
aussi rené de le temps de venir avec
votre famille vos amis passer un moment
vous détendre et passer un très bon
moment avec vos enfants des étoiles dans
les arbres mais aussi dans les yeux des
petits et des grands
moi je suis de passage sur l'île de la
réunion
soudain forum de la famille donc voilà
je suis venu avec les neveux et nièces
quand trouvé sa juste magique
il a été
vraiment vraiment
démerdez vous
or tout ce qu'il ya
a sion ils ont beaucoup aimé 5,9 et
la magie de noël c'est la première fois
je viens et c'est génial c'est bien une
nomination les petits manèges pour ça
que les enfants c'est bien
et puis ça permet aussi aux
petits-enfants de remporter pas une
telle chose quoi voilà est basse et
s'écrit très bon et je trouve que la
fête elle m'amuse beaucoup
c'est chouette
inspicio jeudi
[Musique]
une première soirée féerique qui s'est
achevée par un spectacle de son et
lumière qui aura lieu chaque soir
jusqu'au 21 décembre
[Musique]